- [Lecturer] Let's do a work example
where we calculate the standard change
in free energy, delta G naught,
for a chemical reaction.
And for our reaction,
let's look at the synthesis of ammonia gas
from nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas.
At 25 degrees Celsius,
delta H naught for this reaction is equal
to negative 92.2 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
Since delta H naught is negative,
this reaction is exothermic
and at 25 degrees Celsius,
delta S naught for this reaction is equal
to negative 198.7 joules
per kelvin mole of reaction.
Our goal is to calculate delta G naught
for this reaction at 25 degrees Celsius.
Remember if delta G naught is negative,
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically favorable,
but if delta G naught is positive,
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically unfavorable.
Since the change in enthalpy is negative,
and the change in entropy is negative,
whether or not delta G naught is negative
depends on the temperature.
To calculate the value for delta G naught,
we're going to use the following equation.
Delta G naught is equal to delta H naught
minus T delta S naught,
where T is the temperature in kelvin.
Next, we need to plug
everything into our equation.
So delta H nought is equal
to negative 92.2 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
The temperature is 25 degrees Celsius.
So 25 plus 273 is equal to 298 kelvin.
So we're gonna plug 298
kelvin into our equation.
And for delta S naught,
notice we have this in joules,
whereas for delta H naught,
it was in kilojoules.
So we need to convert delta S naught
into kilojoules per
kelvin mole of reaction.
One way to do that is just to move
the decimal place three to the left,
which gives us negative 0.1987 kilojoules
per kelvin mole of reaction.
So we're gonna plug all of
this in for delta S naught.
Here's our equation with
everything plugged in.
Notice that kelvin will cancel out,
which gives us kilojoules per
mole of reaction as our units.
And when we do the math,
we find that delta G naught is equal
to negative 33.0 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
Because delta G naught is negative,
that means the reaction is
thermodynamically favorable
in the forward direction.
And the superscript naught
means that both the reactants
and products are in their standard states.
So what our calculation tells
us is if we had a mixture
of nitrogen, hydrogen, and ammonia gas
at 25 degrees Celsius,
and all three gases had a partial pressure
of one atmosphere,
the reaction is
thermodynamically favorable
in the forward direction,
meaning nitrogen gas and
hydrogen gas would come together
to synthesize or make more ammonia.
So at 298 kelvin, delta G naught
for this reaction is negative.
Let's do another calculation
for the same reaction
at a different temperature,
a temperature of 1,000 kelvin.
Also, even though the
value for delta G naught
is highly dependent on temperature,
the values for delta H
naught and delta S naught
are not as dependent on the temperature.
Therefore, we're gonna
assume that these values
for delta H naught and
delta S naught don't change,
and we're gonna use the same ones
at the higher temperature of 1,000 kelvin.
Here's the equation with
everything plugged in
for the calculation of delta G naught
at the higher temperature of 1,000 kelvin.
And notice that the values
we're using for delta H naught
and delta S naught are
the same as the ones
that we used at the lower
temperature of 298 kelvin.
Once again, kelvin cancels out
and gives us kilojoules
per mole of reaction
as our units for our final answer.
And after we do the math,
we find that delta G naught is equal
to positive 106.5 kilojoules
per mole of reaction.
Since delta G naught is positive,
that means the forward reaction
is thermodynamically unfavorable,
which means the reverse reaction
is thermodynamically favorable.
So if we had a mixture of
nitrogen gas, hydrogen gas,
and ammonia gas at a
temperature of 1,000 kelvin,
and all three gases had a partial pressure
of one atmosphere,
the ammonia gas would
turn into nitrogen gas
and hydrogen gas.
And while we have both
calculations on the screen,
let's analyze why one calculation
gives a negative value
for delta G naught,
and the other one gives a positive value.
For the calculation at 298 kelvin,
the temperature was low enough
that the entropy term didn't overwhelm
the negative value for the enthalpy term,
and we ended up with a
negative overall value
for delta G naught.
However, for the
calculation at 1,000 kelvin,
this time the temperature was high enough
where the entropy term outweighed
the negative value for the enthalpy term,
and therefore the overall value
for delta G naught
ended up being positive.
We've just seen that for
the synthesis of ammonia
from nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas
at relatively low
temperatures like 298 kelvin,
delta G naught is less than zero,
and at relatively high
temperatures like 1,000 kelvin,
delta G naught is greater than zero.
So there must be some temperature
between 298 kelvin and 1,000 kelvin
where the forward reaction goes
from being thermodynamically favorable
to thermodynamically unfavorable.
And this crossover point
occurs when the enthalpy term
and the entropy term
are perfectly balanced.
Therefore, delta G naught is equal to zero
at this crossover point.
So we plug in zero for delta G naught
and we solve for the temperature
at the crossover point.
After some algebra,
we find that the temperature is equal
to delta H naught divided
by delta S naught,
which is equal to negative 92.2 kilojoules
per mole of reaction divided
by negative 0.1987 kilojoules
per kelvin mole of reaction.
Kilojoules per mole of
reaction cancels out
and gives us 464 kelvin for
the crossover temperature.
So for this particular reaction,
delta G naught is equal
to zero at 464 kelvin.
At temperatures less than 464 kelvin,
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically favorable.
However, at temperatures
higher than 464 kelvin,
the forward reaction is
thermodynamically unfavorable.